I mentioned Kyle van Noy he had two
sacks eight tackles quarterback head two
forced fumbles and the Patriots leading
with their defense again beating up the
Buffalo Bills are you guys gonna be
watching film today I'm doing great
congratulations on the game yesterday so
you have film section because I would
like to come into your place well I like
your little set and you got up with the
cows I mean I need to come check it out
one of these days all right I got a
basketball court I don't know how what
kind of basketball game you got I'm not
the typical football player I feel like
I can not only play defense or rebound
right I just do it a little bit okay
best basketball player you have to be
we'll play a little game of pours I
don't want to steal your money okay yeah
I'm not afraid always down yeah I always
tell people if you're afraid buy a dog
because I have no problem shooting
against you Kyle pretty confident I like
that until you watch Game film today
yeah we'll check it out we'll see you
know we'll do a plays we get cussed out
over and plays that we get afraid for
but you know I think at the end of the
day we'll we'll have a good meeting
there's a lot to learn from yesterday
I'm just kind of happy we battled up in
Buffalo buffalo because a good football
team
they have really good players on peace
and special teams offensively they're
putting pieces together and you know the
head coach has done a great job and you
know it was a good team win for us wait
wait wait you don't have to do the
Patriots way with with this interview
Kyle like you don't have to say do you
have a script right there that says
let's see team is great on defense is
great quarterbacks great a team effort
coaches great fans great yeah we know I
know that's why I'm saying okay
scat Kaiulani had a great game and he
won't give me the Patriots way here I
mean you you had Josh Allen scared yeah
I do like you did a little bit he was a
little shook in the pocket and you know
he gave David some chances to turn the
ball over and JT Jackson had to dev had
a great play and we just had talked of
pressure on them I feel like we've been
doing that from the start of the season
all the way back in training camps and
you guys are just gonna having fun right
now
and we know it's early it's September
you know just got to keep battling it's
a long season and we're just excited to
have the opportunity each and every week
to play ball and play with each other
this group's been out together for a
while and we just want to keep it going
all right okay I gotta take I gotta take
exception with something you said that
you know you guys want some respect here
feel under right okay
you're the Patriots are known as a
defensive team this year Kyle you guys
are probably one of the two or three
best defenses team defensive teams you
got an unbelievable secondary there
maybe the best secondary in football is
it because Brady gets to my let's brain
blame this on Brady gets too much
attention and you guys don't get enough
is that really what this comes down to
[Music]
[Laughter]
your defense is great man you're making
my head get bigger bigger right now
Brady deserves the attention man what
he's done what he does each and every
week obviously he didn't have his best
performance but yesterday but you know
the defense we've always felt were
underrated and underappreciated by
people but we appreciate each other and
at the end of the day I think Tom knows
how good the defense is and how good it
in years past years has ever been talked
about we kind of proved it last year we
were trying to keep proving it each and
every year every year it's different and
you know we all feel underrated on
defense we are a lotta you I would say
we got a lot of elite football players
and you know people are starting to know
it's a little bit but we need to keep it
rolling
it's September and you know we still got
a lot to prove I know myself I'm pretty
hungry
I feel like you've had a really good
linebacker core here and we added Jamie
and a couple other players and we just
want to keep proving it each and every
week that we can play some ball what was
it like first time you met Brady after
you came over from the lines I depart as
a funny story so after I got traded I
had to do a physical at 5:30 in the
morning and he was in the locker room
and I was finishing washing my hands
after going to the restroom and he walks
he walks by through the locker room and
introduced himself like hey my name's
Tom Brady you are I know you are you
idiot you know what are you doing trying
to say hi to me like it like a normal
person bro your before you're 40 years
old introducing yourself I never heard
or know who you are your try I was a
year out and at first it kind of catches
you off guard like is he serious but
when you talk to them and you realize
that's the person he is it doesn't
matter who you are you treat everybody
the same
like he introduces himself to everyone
which I really appreciate and respect
because it could be it and you can be
able and he chooses to be just a good
person it's funny because people when I
tell people that my god I just want to
hate them but you know you can't
neighborhood hey though he's just a good
dude you
should have said I'm sorry I didn't
catch your name what is it I would are
you a kicker like what are you what do
you what do you do here yeah easy there
he's I don't want you to get in trouble
there with TB 12 there and
congratulations I was a fan of yours
when you were at BYU and even when you
were with the Lions when nobody else
watched I did but I'm glad you're
getting a lot of credit by the way you
guys won the Super Bowl because of your
defense last year so it's not like
you're surprising anybody Kyle there's
no snow pity party here you guys have
maybe as go-to defense as anybody in
football this year well I appreciate it
but I'm gonna keep telling myself we
gotta keep we guys we gotta keep that
motivation man we you know we're hungry
for success our teams you know really
really we want to want to be the bed and
you know we don't want to just talk
about it because we've never done that
least want to continue to show it and
every week and play some ball anyplace
anytime anywhere well you're welcome in
the man cave make sure you bring plenty
of money and you know yeah yeah wait you
know what bring Edelman to I'll take his
money too and then bring in Brady we'll
do some beers we'll see who can dry it
down some beers Brady can beat everybody
drinking beers yeah he you ever know my
shotgun a couple egg Kyle
congratulations and hopefully we'll
cross paths one of these days
man have a boy that's a Kyle van Noy I
loved him at BYU and then he went to the
Lions and then kind of forgot about him
then with the Patriots got him I said
that dude
Bella Jack's gonna love him you can plug
and play for more Dan Patrick show tune
in to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]